Vậy việc đào qua tâm anh, lên tiếp xác nhận ki lúc này hộ kwi tụng,
Joe Mb, i UI, i bếp nhất Việt Nam,
tổ chứng ki lúc Việt Nam, sức nhất này hộ bầu gắng,
i bếp, tâm anh, tại vì việc đào qua tâm anh hà nốt
và tình bố hồ chí mình là những sự kiện ki lúc kwi tụng,
Joe Mb, i UI, i bếp nhất Việt Nam.
Lần đầu tiên, các gia đình có sức phát điểm khăn nhau,
gặp những tình chạm bệnh li khăn nhau,
mong con tìm một năm, ba năm năm năm năm,
đến hàng chục năm, k há biệt, đến tạp hà niệm một năm,
mặc sĩ chỉ đánh làm gì vậy?
Bộ lòng hà trông.
Đã là lúc là một...
anh bốc kơi dạy đến.
Trong tục năm, khui, mấy...
Mấy, mấy, mấy, mấy, mấy, mấy, mấy.
Tử dụng, ở đây, đột cái thầm thảm gì vậy, ngàn.
Hảm ốc hội?
Sự bình rương, hảm ốc kìa được mấy thầm như tay,
đại giúp vệ trọng mình có đứa ra,
tìv tên gần như thế này, tìv tên bằng mình đứa vẻ!
Nhạc sự dân thầy đặc khác của mình là là lýt này như những cái không ký vô nhắc nữa
Đi ra đi, không?
Ngà, hà ngàng sò vào analytics.
Còn hà ngàng sò phó tổng, nhaếu vô này,
và chờ đã vẻ me ngủ ngủ ngủ với dế táng.
Bỏ hối tâm năm,距 với Tạm Anh không chỉ tạo ra.
Mặc bân khuc khoía mà con phân phét hi vọc,
chỉ lành được trải tim tương v econ vơ,
Để đêm đêm đêm hệ phúc xọc vệ cho các gia đình trong vòng ngoài nước
Mời mỗi em đẻ sinh ra từ các phương pháp của trợ sinh sản ai lua Ad-Ap
không chỉ là một phép mồ của i học mà là bằng chiếm của tình yêu của lòng kinh chi và nhìn tiến mắt liệt
Hăng chục lý ném đẻ chào đời quay mạnh là thành qua của sự kết hợp cả hệ tổ
Tự trang thiết bị giết đại hệ thống sách nghiệp tin tiền nè chần đa chi sắc
phoàn dễ bệnh liếp mộn lắm nước
Chỉ định đúng phát xin dục tốt với các phát độ cả thế quá phố hợp với tình gray bệnh
Chào cuối trình chần vồi đúng thời điểm đúng kiến thuật
Đồ ngũ trên biên phùi học rồi
Títà và lùi cây phùi thay thành công với những mấy móc hiện đại nhấn
Vào sừng vui hợp tự đổi ngũ trên ra nè mọc sản phụ qua
Nội tết chần đoạn hình anh sẽ nghiệp xa vọc mấy và tế bảo